eccentric billionaire howard hughes was
once the owner of channel 8 and he lived
in a house behind the studios back in
the 1950s that home is still here with
many of mr hughes's possessions inside
legend has it that his spirit is felt
inside the walls of the home so with the
help of some friends i tried to contact
the spirit of howard hughes take a look
[Music]
so this is howard hughes's actual house
he lived here in the 1950s today we're
trying to reach out to the spirit of
howard hughes i'm a big howard hughes
fan he said work i brought my holy water
did you really yes you had a feeling you
were good i had a feeling
that you see the exorcist yeah yeah
that's what i got you have a seat let me
see which seat
okay
so the object
it's a light
it's a light it's less than hammerman
so the object here is for us to try to
reach out and get in touch with our
hughes and you know and see what we can
get so calm directly i have this number
you got it yeah is it what was it 1800
collections what was it yeah yeah it's
down in the center did you feel anything
when you walked in this house has
definitely got stuff there's something
right now we're not going to do this
alone i've got a friend okay who mama
voodoo mama voodoo mama voodoo
get out of here
hello i am mama voodoo
i am a seventh generation
hexa which is an austrian german which
and i brought
the family ouija board
with me well wait yeah am i doing the
ouija no are you comfortable using one
of these yeah i mean i had the uh the
parker brothers hold on yeah this one
looks like it's the real
this is the this is the real deal howard
hughes we are calling your spirit here
today
we are close to the veil sowwin is only
a few days away so the veil is thin
please come through to us
please give us your message do you mind
that people
are in your home mr muse
this is like
this thing is it's like lit
it's like lead
um
[Music]
this is like right now i'm gonna go i
just got a text is that from him you
think
oh see okay that's okay so what does
that mean um he's not happy
mr use
wow that's like dead weight it's like
dead weight it won't move
it's like dead
um mr hughes can you can you give us a
sign please uh another sign that it's
really you
that's a picture of his mother what
that card just moved no dude are you
doing this what am i doing howard
what
what sorry no sorry um the the photo of
howard's mother just moved
right
did he just bail yes he just bailed like
he literally bailed can we ask ask him
to ring the bell
mr
hughes they're asking you to
ring the bell to prove that you are in
this room
mr hughes if you were still alive today
would you see carrot top's show one for
yes
two for no
there's gotta be another oh he would
you don't mind i'm very nervous i needed
money to do
[Laughter]
[Applause]
present yourself mr howard hughes
kendall teddy's title time
howard present yourself
howard
oh my gosh